good morning John it's Friday this time
last week and this is a little hard to
believe considering the weather we're
having here in Missoula right now I was
pulling out of Port Everglades on a
beautiful sunny evening in a boat and
let's be honest it wasn't really about
technically it was a ship more
technically it was a 150,000 ton 240
foot tall 1111 foot long 183 foot wide
floating luxury hotel with a climbing
wall in a basketball court in mini-golf
and at Johnny Rockets and for swimming
pools and precariously placed hot tubs
and several beautiful performance venues
and an arcade and a beautiful dining
room that casino and weird big red dogs
in the mall and a giant cake and
freaking ice skating rinks a ship that
burns eight thousand gallons of fuel per
hour which it uses not just to power the
engines but to distill seawater for us
to surf on power over a dozen elevators
keep the ice cold in the hot tubs hot
while environmentalist tank is rebelling
against the very existence of this thing
scientist Hank wants to know how does
this work how on earth was it ever even
created in the first place the massive
technological and logistical inputs
required to keep it moving and floating
and safe and happy the goal in fact
seemed to be for us to just completely
forget that we were on a ship at all
that's to just imagine that you're in a
quite nice entertainment venue that just
happens to be experiencing the longest
most laid-back earthquake of all time so
I was on the ship for the fourth annual
Joko cruise crazy a floating nerd
adventure featuring semi celebrity nerds
like John Hodgman Peter sagal John
Scalzi Pomplamoose Molly Lewis the
DoubleClick's Paul and storm Paula
Tompkins Grant Imahara
Wil Wheaton me and of course Jonathan
Coulton the Joko of Joko crew is crazy
it was pretty clear from day one that
the biggest advantage of being on this
cruise was not all the luxury amenities
and not the free room service and not
never being more than 12 feet away from
a hot tub it was being locked on a boat
with cool people with no escape except
for watery oblivion every day John
Hodgman sat in a hot tub for two hours
answering questions I got exposed to
towns I never knew existed got to meet
my idols got to hang out with a bunch of
awesome nerdfighters and that's what all
the people armed the crews were there
for yeah we stopped in Caribbean islands
and swam with stingrays and snorkelled
and went on the longest zipline over
water in the world and saw this goat
we cut on a grave in Jamaica and yes
those were cool experiences but it
occurs to me that the real value of this
somewhat monstrous technological marvel
is to give us a kind of ancient
simplified life a small community where
you can walk everywhere seeing the same
people every day people that share your
values and interests and passions and
experiences a place to be foolish and
comfortable and joyful and proud and
somehow these days we require an awful
lot of complexity to get back to
simplicity now I know that cities are
valuable and then the Internet is lovely
and we can't live that sort of insular
life every day but I'll tell you what
six days didn't even feel like long
enough does it have to be on a boat that
consumes a gallon of gas every 12 feet
maybe not but I don't know how else to
pull it off I will be thinking about
that though I'll also be thinking about
sunshine because this is a bunch of
false
Jarnell oh my god I can't even go there
this is just a lake now John I'll see
you on Tuesday
[Applause]